it's almost two weeks since the strike
at machika and the funerals are
happening every day now burial notices
though kept Under Wraps relatives
ordered to keep quiet the freshly
bereaved desperately sad and desperately
angry she was incredibly upset refused
to talk to us said that she hated
foreigners said why are you helping the
ukrainians
and that's just a constant refrain you
can understand from someone who's just
that lost their relative why why is the
West helping Ukraine at the cost of our
loved ones
it was a us-made high mass missile which
killed Russia says 89 of its servicemen
the ukrainians say as many as 400 the
largest mass casualty Russia has
admitted to so far in this war and a
strike they blamed on the soldiers
themselves for supposedly using their
mobile phones
many of the men came from in and around
the southern city of Samara a terrible
start to the New Year here
it makes even basic news Gathering hard
and frustrating
thank you
sir yeah but we do find the occasional
glimpse of honesty
you've not people are dying for nothing
only because of one fool this woman says
now are carefully managed by the
regional Governor he held a video link
up for surviving Soldiers with their
relatives back home the pr they want to
put out
one serviceman told of the arrival of
his baby girl the night before and other
messages of support for the troops Come
Home With Victory their wives tell them
in Samara itself there's not much now to
Mark what happened just this graffiti
Samara machevka we remember we mourn the
artist too patriotic he said to give Sky
News an interview
but we do find Skeptics those who don't
agree with what's happening even if
they're scared to say much
[Music]
but there aren't many like him and in
this city hit by recent tragedy we meet
not so much sorrow as just silence
Russia's home front forced to hide its
scars behind closed doors
down a magnet Sky News Samara Russia